right we're picking up the racket
pickleball it is the fastest growing
sport in America and this morning Aloha
Shores Park is proving the pickleball is
for everyone Candace Charles joining us
from their new Courts at Buffalo West
Cheyenne I saw that you're working on
your serve nobody needs to wear helmets
Candace everyone's safe over there no
Heather no one needs to wear a helmet
because I am now a pro just kidding
thanks to the wonderful pickleball
Ambassador as well as Cinderella
pickleball president Brian Day Wilkins
thank you so much for joining us tell me
a little bit about these new courts here
what do you think oh I'm having a blast
out here these are perfect Courts for
beginners and that's what we're going to
do we're gonna going to have some fun
today on the courts awesome
it's me he
ccsdpe teacher he's seen the programs
now in the schools tell us how it's
going and are we getting these students
learning well it's going really well we
do uh some professional development for
pickleball with the teachers as they get
the excitement it gets the kids going
it's awesome stuff right now awesome
okay so we're gonna play a little bit of
a game here I think Jared who has who
has the ball somebody has the ball yes
there's the ball there's the volcano
what is this that we're gonna do
starting out we're gonna start out doing
Drop shots we're going to practice here
we're gonna hit balls to their before
their feet it's called a dink okay let's
do it think here we go and I've been
ready Heather and I've been practicing
so I think I'm gonna do kind of okay yes
yes okay close yes and it really is for
everyone as you can see you guys can
find out a little bit more about Aloha
Shores which is open every day seven to
eleven as well as the new courts here
and the programming on our website
newsnow.com for now live from Aloha
Shores nope I'm Candice Charles
number three you were two for three that
was great good job Candace appreciate
you well all right have a good have a
good day out there stay safe have fun
all right